enfin le tribunal
on sent les sorties du nouvel ensemble
est sorti d'une vanne mais c'est un
miracle ouais on est sorti d'une baisse
oui mais vous voyez ce que je vois au
moins encore le magnéto mais c'est pas
possible ça mais ça c'est vraiment
impossible évidemment comme c'est
impossible alors ils l'ont fait appel à
nous ce bon m face toute façon c'est
parlant par la porte elle comprend qu
est-ce qui a maintenant 20 mois on va
voir qu'est ce que c'est bonjour
monsieur monsieur hausse il est environ
20 sur 35
votre mission consiste vous acceptez
avec l'antenne de tf1 jusqu'à 21h 35 ou
40 après vous pourrez rentrer chez vous
ou ailleurs où aller autrement ou dans
un ordre différent mais pendant ce temps
là il vous faut obligatoirement pour des
raisons que vous savez est de la plus
haute importance joindre et engagé coûte
que coûte pour cette tranche horaire
frank sinatra les bee gees l'a jamais
nabli harry belafonte et shirley
maclaine john travolta et sammy davis
junior
j'ajoute que si vous ou l'un de vos
collaborateurs et est en danger nous ne
pourrions rien faire pour vous à la fin
des messages la bande s'autodétruira
elle-même vous verrez de la fumée n'ayez
pas peur elle sera parfumé l'eucalyptus
pour les cordes vocales
bonne chance et à bientôt tu peux
respirer ça fait du bien
alors ils sont complètement fous au
quartier général
je sais pas si en avril engagé comme
directeur à je ne sais pas d'où des
drôles bord d'un casque alors moi
comment je vais faire moi pour rejoindre
john travolta frank sinatra
si ça se trouve ils sont même pas chez
eux à cette heure ci sont peut-être même
au restaurant qui viennent de quitter le
restaurant ou alors peut-être qu'ils
sont en train de chercher un veston oui
surtout samedi soir c'est bourré partout
il ya du monde comme ça partout partout
partout à l'horrible alors il doit
peut-être sur leur beau parent oui c'est
ça comme ça ils n'ont pas de frais
alors comment faire la main comme en
paix avec les frais je crois que je suis
des missions impossibles à boire alors
moi je vais vous dire ça c'est une
émission impossible avec ces photos
c'est encore de plus en plus impossible
alors monsieur moi je crois que peut
vous sauver la situation j'ai d'autres
photos à vous montrer si vous voulez
jetter un oeil et on pourra s'en sortir
sans payer les frais déplacements les
frais de voyage de près de bristol
alors ça vaut quoi prairies et jai des
photos si vous voulez jeter un objet des
photos et qu'est ce que vous avez contre
tous j'ai des photos ggg tunis et
casablanca le port la pêcherie j'ai par
exemple le constantine la place
d'abréger la rue caraman glg la place du
gouvernement
j'ai pu beaucoup de photos marie golse
une amie rigole mais je ne sais pas une
émission sur les collections des cartes
postales mais alors quoi qu'est ce que
vous voulez à la boule un plateau
voulait des artistes oui mais alors j'ai
pour vous pour vous sauver la situation
au gb c'est le dernier recours
la dernière affaire que ce nom ne dit
pas non plus une équipe d'artistes
première qualité classe internationale
un plateau unique au monde avant et on
peut les avoir ce soit on peut les avoir
ce soir il peut les avoir ce soir
montrer alors écoutez c'est parce que je
connais par coeur on a l'équipe de
pénélope la comédie musicale on a un
décor dit on à susanna rinaldi on
atténue la claque on a eu cette saleté
le proverbe castel catherine bardet je
voulais de plus vous voulez rouler alors
je vais vous dire quelque chose à mon
ami oui vous m'avez sauvé la mise assez
normal avait sommé vraiment sauvé la
mise est normal on est en équipe c'est
normal mais ce que j'ai oublié de vous
dire est ce que le quartier général n'a
pas prévu c'est que vous êtes compris
dans le dans l'émission et vous devez
chanter ah bon je chante pas en playback
j'espère en playback
avec eux on dirait en direct avec un
grand port quai avec le grand orchestre
dirigé par mon ami jean claude weil
kaboul avait enlevé de la bouche qui
tombaient